piensa la campaña presidencial en
francia con el anuncio de las
candidaturas
la líder de la extrema derecha más del
epen espera que la tercera sea la
vencida lópez hizo de la lucha contra la
migración su bandera roja para down wow
no habrá lugar en francia donde no se
aplique la ley
amigos míos erradicaremos barrios
peligrosos pandillas mafias y todos
aquellos islamistas o no que quieran
imponernos reglas y una forma de vida
que no es nuestro es de más o menos
en francia los franceses tienen derecho
a vivir como los franceses jose
más temprano la alcaldesa de parís anne
hidalgo hizo lo propio la primera mujer
en ocupar ese cargo puso precisamente
como prioridad los derechos de las
mujeres dependerá de las mujeres
decidirlo dependerá de los franceses
decidirlo serán ellos quienes transmitan
la idea de que las mujeres en puestos de
responsabilidad marcan una diferencia
positiva en la vida de las mujeres y los
hombres hija de una pareja de españoles
que huyeron de la dictadura franquista
francia representa al partido socialista
según reuters en las últimas encuestas
el presidente manuel marco cuenta con el
24 por ciento de la intención de voto
lepén con el 20 e hidalgo con un 8% la
ahora candidata para las elecciones del
2022 buscará unir la fragmentada
izquierda francesa